[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec à mes côtés kathia
gilder bonjour cata bonjour oriane est
notre invité cette semaine sébastien
chenu bonjour vous êtes député du nord
porte parole du front national on va
revoir cette semaine riche en actualité
avec vous d'abord la présentation du
projet de loi immigration et asile sous
des critiques le texte prévoit notamment
de réduire les délais d'examen de la
demande d'asile est de faciliter les
expulsions
faut-il mieux encadrer les écoles hors
contrat oui préconisait sénateurs une
proposition de loi était examiné un
rapport du sénat dénonce les
conséquences de la baisse des contrats
aidés sur les collectivités il préconise
une diminution progressive de ces
contrats et puis les élections
européennes l'assemblée a voté un projet
loi qui valait notamment le retour à une
circonscription unique et on commence la
semaine par le projet de loi asile et
immigration présenté en conseil des
ministres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mieux maîtriser l'immigration mais aussi
mieux accueillir c'est la philosophie de
ce projet de loi que gérard collomb
qualifie d' équilibré le gouvernement
dit vouloir s'aligner sur le droit
européen mais le texte divise au sein
même de la majorité le ministre de
l'intérieur a tenté de déminer le
terrain
maïté frémont au menu du projet de loi
asile et immigration deux grands
chantiers le premier la réduction des
délais de la procédure d'asile à six
mois contre 11 en moyenne actuellement
pour cela les délais d'instruction
devrait être réduit les procédures
accélérées multipliés et les délais pour
déposer son dossier strictement limitées
il faut que les procédures soient
semblables entre les différents pays
sous peine évidemment d'être le pays de
dernier ressort
et si vous demain vous avez 3 400 mille
personnes qui s'installent ici vous ne
saurez pas les accueillir
est il permis non leur vie marginalisée
dans les quartiers déjà en grande
difficulté les demandeurs d'asile
pourront également être obligés de
s'installer dans une région particulière
l'objectif du gouvernement équilibré
leur répartition sur le territoire
deuxième chantier de ce projet de loi le
renforcement de la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale
le gouvernement ne s'en cache pas il
veut augmenter le nombre d'expulsions
avec notamment l'allongement des
rétentions administratives de 45 à 90
jours voire 135 en cas d'obstruction
parmi les autres mesures du projet doigt
l'augmentation de 16 à 24 heures de la
durée de la retenue administratives pour
vérifier le droit au séjour ou encore le
renforcement des pouvoirs
d'investigation notamment sur les prises
d'empreintes
ce texte est contestée par de nombreuses
associations
mais entre fermeté et humanité il est
juge
et équilibrée par le gouvernement un
avis bien loin d'être partagée au sein
même de la majorité
c'est un texte équilibré selon lui nous
n'avons pas forcément la même vision de
l'équilibré que nous sommes sur des
mesures techniques qui ne vont pas au
fond des choses
nous laissons de côté bon nombre de
dispositions sur lesquelles il faudrait
que nous puissions travailler
donc je disais dans mon rapport l'autre
jour que nous faisons un texte où les
seize mois nous allons en ajouter un
autre selon moi pour donner un aspect
plus sociale au projet de loi le premier
ministre edouard philippe le promets les
recommandations d'aurélien tâche et sur
l'intégration des réfugiés seront
intégrés au débat parlementaire
dès le 10 avril prochain fermeté et
répression est ce que pour vous
sébastien chenu ces mots résume le mieux
la politique migratoire d' emmanuel
macron et la ligne de gérard collomb
dans ce projet de loi non pas du tout je
crois que ce qui résume le mieux c'est
ce que vient de dire un député de la
république en marche c'est un texte
technique qui ne s'attaque pas aux
problèmes de fond on est esthétique
louage oui une petite loi administrative
sans autorité sans vision sans fermeté
sans moyens il ya aussi le problème sans
moyens donc on aura comme on l'a souvent
et les textes présentés par le
gouvernement macron un débat puis une
absence totale des faits qui accouchera
la montagne a accouché d'une souris
une absence totale des faits si on
souhaite contrôler les politiques
migratoires
si on souhaite empêcher davantage
d'immigration dans notre pays je pense
que c'est pas la philosophie durs pour
qualifier ce projet là ce n'est pas trop
de voir escales de l'accueil les bonnes
mesures dans ce texte surnom c'est une
imposture helmand par ce gouvernement
nous dit on va être plus sévère alors on
va faire attention et que la réalité
derrière il ne met pas de moyens je vous
donne un exemple le nombre de places
dans les centres de rétention
administrative
il y a deux cents places je crois de
plus prévues dans le texte
c'est ridicule par rapport au nombre de
personnes qui seraient en capacité ou
dans la nécessité d'aller dans des
centres dans ces centres de rétention
administrative
on est tellement loin de ce qu'il faudra
faire qu'en réalité le gouvernement avec
une petite cuillère à café trou et
essaye de combler la brèche de ce qu'il
faut bien dire
une submersion migratoire qui s'abat sur
notre pays et ce texte est sous le feu
de certaines critiques notamment celles
du défenseur de droits qui estime que le
demandeur d'asile et mal traitée avec ce
texte comment vous réagissez à ça oui
enfin le défenseur des droits monsieur
toubon qu'on a connu plus plus ferme
d'ailleurs dans d'autres dans d'autres
moments de sa vie
il est payé pour faire ça et il est payé
pour prendre la défense des migrants de
faire et bien moi unités de non non non
moi je suis payé voyez vous je suis élu
est payé pour défendre mes compatriotes
et je pense que dans le cas présent dans
le cas d'espèce les propositions du
député aurélien taché et bien font état
d'une préférence migratoire quand vous
donnez
c'est dans les propositions d'aurélien
tâche et qui seront intégrés au débat
parlementaire d'après ce que j'ai
compris quand vous donnez une impasse
culture de 500 euros à chaque demandeur
d'asile quel français consacre 500 euros
par an à l'accès à la culture
certainement pas des électeurs du nord
qui ont suffisamment de difficultés
possibles il ya une préférence
migratoires à travers ce texte et à
travers les recommandations qu'ils ont
fait qui va évidemment à l'encontre de
ce qu'il faudrait alors vous allez
avancé vous avez annoncé vouloir
présenter un contre-projet sébastien
chenu que va contenir ce contre-projet
il
il va être il va reposer sur trois
piliers un contre projet avec d'abord
une un projet de loi constitutionnelle
une proposition de la part dans
constitutionnel sur deux serait la
proposition de loi oui ce sera
probablement on est en train de
l'affiner mais ce rapprochement une
proposition de loi avec probablement la
nécessité de revenir sur le droit du sol
et puis il y aura toute une batterie
après d'arguments de propositions très
concrètes très technique
et puis ce qu'on appelle un cahier
d'action c'est à dire équivalent liste
également tous les soucis tous les
problèmes on gagne ce texte à sa tâche
ne s'attaque pas par exemple leur
accompagnement des mineurs étrangers qui
a explosé dans notre pays deux milliards
d'euros + 100 % schengen
les causes les conséquences ce texte ne
s'attaquent ni aux causes ni aux
conséquences est ce que dit d'ailleurs
le député la république en personne les
mineurs étrangers d'un philippe
annoncera des solutions le 6 mars en au
département on va changer de sujet
sébastien chenu le sénat qui veut
encadrer plus fermement les écoles
privées hors contrat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mercredi par 240 voix contre 94 les
sénateurs ont adopté une proposition de
loi qui encadre plus sévèrement les
écoles hors contrat 65 mille élèves sont
dans des écoles qu'il est facile
d'ouvrir et qui recrutent les
professeurs comme elle le souhaite
françoise gatel sénatrice centriste
auteur de la proposition de loi a repéré
une école à toulouse avec des
enseignants fiesch vs
on l'écouté on avait des d une partie
d'enseignants un fichier s des pratiques
absolument incompatible avec les lois de
la république
le tribunal correctionnel a fini par
ordonner la fermeture de cette école qui
a rouvert sous un autre nom dans les
mêmes locaux il est même en ces
enseignants et le tribunal administratif
a annulé la décision de fermeture au
prétexte que les motifs invoqués n'était
pas conforme à la loi
est ce que c'est une bonne chose c'est
la science choisi d'instaurer une base
légale pour fermer ces alors contraint
bien souvent centriste où les
républicains se cacher le petit doigt et
baning et elle nous dit on va s'attaquer
aux écoles hors contrat qui lui pose
problème en est et non elle veut
s'attaquer aux écoles hors contrat
islamistes alors il faut le dire il faut
dire les choses parce que les écoles
hors contrat qui pose problème si on
parle des écoles montessori
moi je ne souhaite pas qu'on s'attaque
aux écoles montessori il ya des tas de
dinelli personnels qui sont là il ya
déjà la liberté d'enseignement dans ce
pays qui existe d'ailleurs madame nissen
je crois me la culture elle-même était à
l'origine d'une école hors contrat
donc en réalité il faut s'attaquer aux
écoles qui pose problème réellement et
le dire et dire ce que c'est à ce sont
des écoles dans laquelle il ya ou des
professeurs comme l a dit qu'ils peuvent
avoir des comportements des discours et
des profils types fichier s est il faut
donner la possibilité aux préfets de les
fermer immédiatement refusé le
financement étranger de ces écoles il
faut dire les choses pour était de se
cacher derrière son petit doigt
oui à la liberté d'enseignement dans
notre pays qui paie cole montessori
aconfessionnel etc et de l'autre côté
s'attaquer aux écoles dans lesquelles il
ya un danger pour la république est
donné les moyens non pas aux tribunaux
mais au préfet immédiatement de fermer
les écoles qui pourrait la touche à la
liberté pédagogique de liberté
dans notre pays on y tient la gauche
essaie de la ruine et il ya quelques
années on y tient mais il ya les écoles
confessionnelles islamistes qui l'école
ça fait partie des lieux prioritaire à
surveiller d'après le plan de
déradicalisation de nouveaux plants
dernier l'association qui est présenté
aujourd'hui par le premier ministre ce
qu'on pensait qu'un assignant un
enseignant les moyens de repérer des
éventuels cas de radicalisation dans une
école
on a déjà eu ce débat dans l'hémicycle
nous nous avons demandé par exemple
qu'on arrête le business de la
déradicalisation ya des tas
d'associations dans ce pays par les
millions d'euros bien sûr pour des
radicaliser soi-disant une jeunesse il
n'y a aucun effet il n'y a aucun
résultat donc là le gouvernement
s'attaque par la petite porte par le
petit bout alors qu'il y à des sujets
prioritaires pour éviter la
radicalisation notre jeunesse dans notre
pays quand on demande qu'on ferme les
mosquées salafistes qu on explique qu'on
expulse les fichiers est étranger etc
ça c'est très concret et ça va bien
soulagé évidemment le professeur qui lui
se retrouve face à des gens dangereux
juste très rapidement faire cette
proposition mais elle va arriver à
l'assemblée nationale vous la vôtre et
on va voir ce que dans si c'est encore
une mesure est sans aucun effet
contraignant sans aucune je vous
rappelle que la dernière campagne du
gouvernement s'étaient stop djihadistes
un site internet qui visait à ne peut à
ceux des radicalités en regardant des
clips vidéo bon bah si c'est dans ce ce
cette mesure là faut pas compter sur six
à neuf il faut voir comment elles
évoluent parce que moi j'ai l'impression
qu'elle se cache derrière son petit
doigt
cette sénatrice donc oui à la
possibilité de fermer des écoles qui
pose problème pour des propos religieux
ou qui ont des financements étrangers ou
dans lequel il ya des fichiers s est
donné la possibilité aux préfets de le
faire très rapidement non à l'idée de
démanteler l'école libre évidemment un
rapport sénatorial juge cette semaine
sévèrement la baisse des contrats aidés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une décision gouvernementale
abaissée à 200 mille le nombre de
contrats aidés en 2018
un rapport sénatorial a étudié les
conséquences de cette baisse ils
déplorent des effets désastreux pour les
collectivités les associations mais
aussi pour les écoles et les ehpad salia
de chair en juillet dernier le
gouvernement a annoncé une baisse
drastique du nombre de contrats aidés de
plus de 450 milles en 2016 on est passé
à 320 milles en 2017 une nouvelle baisse
de 120 mille contrats est prévue pour
cette année deux cent mille contrats
aidés par an c'est totalement
insuffisant pour la mission
d'information sénatoriale qui s'est
penché sur les conséquences de cette
baisse
coauteur du rapport jacques bernard
magner dénoncent une mesure brutale qui
pèsent sur les missions des associations
et collectivités
les personnes concernées ont été les
premières frappes et bien sûr par ses
décisions mais ceux qui avaient compter
sur elle pour le travail qu'ils avaient
à faire à la rentrée notamment dans les
écoles par exemple ou dans les
associations pour la relance des
activités et bien ont été privés de leur
soutien et leur de leur intervention
donc là il ya eu vraiment une brutalité
qu'on ne pouvait pas accepter le rapport
préconise de recréer cent mille contrats
aidés supplémentaires en 2018
la moitié serait réservé aux chômeurs
longue durée de plus de 55 ans l'autre
aux associations de moins de cinq
salariés
jacques bernard magner estime le coût à
un milliard d'euros
moins cher selon lui que d'indemniser
cent mille personnes au chômage
un chômeur coûte plus de 15000 euros par
an à la collectivité et un contrat aidé
et bien suivant le nombre d'heures qu'il
accomplit coûte beaucoup moins cher et
écoute aussi beaucoup moins cher que des
emplois concrets au niveau du smig et
par d
réductions de cotisations sociales
autres pistes proposées dans le rapport
augmenter les moyens des agents de pôle
emploi chargé d'accompagner les
personnes en contrat aidé est ce que
pour vous c'était une bonne idée de
baisser le nombre de ces contrats aidés
est ce que la mesure était pour vous
trop brutale pas nous l'avons dénoncée
et comme bien souvent nous avions fait
l'analyse juste avant les autres oui des
contrats aidés ont un coût c'est une
évidence
oui ce n'est pas la panacée mais ça aide
et ça soutient un certain nombre de
collectivités dans leur quotidien et de
l'autre côté ça ramène dans le champ de
l'emploi des gens qui en sont très
éloignées donc nous avions dit attention
la brutalité de la décision macron de
supprimés à la hache tous les contrats
aidés va avoir des conséquences graves
tous les maires lors des cérémonies de
voeux du mois de janvier ont dénoncé et
moi dans ma circonscription d'abscon
haveluy l'ensemble des collectivités
font appel à des contrats aidés parce
que ça remet des gens sur le chemin de
l'or le nord c'est une preuve
supplémentaire cette décision qu
emmanuelle bach on ne comprend pas les
élus locaux mais ça montre qu'ils
monnayent macro est complètement hors
sol qu'il est complètement hors réalité
de ce pays
il a une vision extrêmement je vais dire
intellectuelle dans lequel il ne
comprend pas les grands équilibres de la
france qui ne comprend pas la vie des
communes ne comprends pas comment ça
fonctionne et nous lui avons dit nous le
front national mais également les élus
locaux à travers l'association des
maires de france et c'est aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui va se passer bas on va
relancer un certain nombre de contrats
aidés donc que de temps perdu que de
gens mis dans des situations difficiles
que deux communes abîmées alors on va
vous parler un peu d'europe puisque en
2019 la france élira ses représentants
au parlement européen et les règles ont
un peu beaucoup changé même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'assemblée a voté un projet de loi qui
entérine notamment le retour à une
circonscription nationale unique c'est
ce qui existe dans la plupart des pays
européens
en clair chaque parti présentera une
seule liste de candidats écoutez ce qu
en pense ce qu'on en pense dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée les eurorégions
elle avait le mérite de rapprocher des
députés européens que m'ont dit déjà
souvent hors sol éloigné des
préoccupations des concitoyens du
terrain et quand je dis du terrain c'est
pas seulement des habitants au quotidien
on imagine mal des citoyennes et
citoyens à aller voir leurs députés
européens tous les jours mais en
particulier des élus locaux
départementaux régionaux qui ont besoin
d'avoir accès à la lisibilité de ce
qu'est l'union européenne aujourd'hui ça
va favoriser également les petits partis
entre guillemets avec le prêt si le
parti le principe de représentativité et
bien sûr la république en marche qui n'a
pas cet ancrage territorial
aujourd'hui il faut quand même que au
parlement européen moi qui était vice
président du parti socialiste européen
il faut quand même qu'ils aient une
représentation quelque chose qui donne à
l'europe cette capacité à bien connaître
l'ensemble des différents territoires
des territoires urbains qui est vaste
je crois que le découpage en
circonscription était complètement
artificielle et ne permettaient pas de
créer une dynamique nationale
ce qui est important il ya énormément
d'abstention donc je crois qu'une
campagne nationale sur une
circonscription nationale peut créer
cette dynamique est aidé par contre je
pense qu on aurait pu avoir une
attention particulière pour l'outre-mer
et peut-être créer une circonscription
d'outre-mer au regard de leurs
spécificités
la crainte que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est
qu'au final l'outre-mer soit mal
représentés au niveau 2 de ces élections
sélaciens chenu vous êtes abstenu lors
du vote de ce tête pourquoi quelle est
votre position
nous sommes favorables à la liste
nationale aucun français ne connaît son
député européen à travers la
circonscription régionale faut pas rêver
ce du baratin quand les républicains
nous disent ça tellement verger du bien
d'autres mesures il a réagi réel dit ça
va permettre à d'autres de pouvoir
siéger s'exprimer être visible bah oui
c'est le but de la démocratie donc nous
on est favorable à une à une liste
nationale en revanche il ya dans ce
texte aussi
une incapacité à permettre à chacun de
s'exprimer à la hauteur de ce qu'il
représente un temps de parole réduit
pour la campagne audiovisuelle
c'est ça c'est pour ça que nous nous
sommes abstenus le csa se réserve un
petit temps de parole qu'il va donner
comme des miettes un certain nombre de
participants entre partis s'ils ne sont
pas représentés à travers un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale nous sommes
représentés à l'assemblée nationale
elles nous aident au second tour de la
présidentielle etc
et là on va avoir quelques miettes pour
parler c'est pour ça qu'on s'est abstenu
l'uefa ne partira seul font ces
élections européennes où il y aura une
liste commune et nicolas dupont aignan
on peut écouter nous notre souhait c'est
de rassembler très largement celles et
ceux qui croient encore en la france
contre l'union européenne donc on va
discuter on va s'ouvrir on va ouvrir les
bras et on verra qui vient vers nous on
est toujours parti indépendamment l'un
de l'autre
dupont aignan et nous mêmes lors des
élections européennes donc on peut
reproduire le schéma mais nous nous
souhaitons intégrer largement à notre
liste des gens venus de tous les
horizons politiques et qui avec nous
crois en la france penser à une rampe
exemple écoutez il ya des personnalités
il ya des partis politiques je pense à
des petits partis politiques mais qui
compte dans la vie politique française
historiquement le cni p&c avec lequel on
a déjà travaillé aux présidentielles
il ya des personnalités venues même
parfois de la société civile qui ont le
même regard qui est propre le même
regard que nous sur ce la nécessaire
lutte que nous devons mener contre
l'union européenne
donc on aimerait pouvoir les accueillir
ont déstabilisé forcément fn pas
forcément vous savez si nous y allons
seuls
eh bien nous avons la capacité d'avoir
une tête de liste maison mais également
de pouvoir accueillir une tête de liste
qui vient avec ses ailleurs ça c'est
déjà passé
je rappelle que le petit fils du général
de gaulle charles de gaulle a mené la
liste du front national il ya quelques
années
donc on sait très bien ouvrir nos listes
à des forces vives de l'extérieur est-ce
que durant ces élections européennes
vous n'allez pas être gêné par florian
philippot qui a incarné la ligne
européenne du fn pendant des années qui
se présentera ces élections nous on a
toujours connu des petites listes
d'extrême droite qui ont existé il y en
avait eu une crise extrême droite balle
en tous les cas j'ai dire que ces
représentants font entre 1 et 2% lors
des élections partielles
donc je ne considère pas que nous
parlions sur le même niveau il n'a pas
d'élu il n'a pas de structure c'est
plutôt une association un fan cuisine
clair le fric site
oui bah c'est son ba écoute et céline de
monsieur asselineau
ils se prennent des voix n'ont pas
vraiment non pas vraiment alors on va
poursuivre sur l'actualité de votre
parti c'est maintenant avec notre
partenaire du figaro.fr et jean jacques
c est avec nous aujourd'hui
katia bonjour bonjour sébastien chenu on
va parler un peu de marion maréchal-le
pen entier fait un un retour sur le
devant de la scène cette semaine elle
était jeudi soir à washington pour une
conférence organisée par les
conservateurs américains
comment marine le pen at elle perçu
cette prestation qui a été beaucoup
commentée dans les médias mais je crois
qu'en fait nous nous sommes assez fiers
de voir que la parole politique que nous
portons même si nous nous la portons sur
le terrain électoral ici en france peut
être accueillis loin de nos frontières
peut retenir l'attention loin de nos
frontières
marion maréchal est parti en bons termes
avec le front national est le
représentant du front national
aujourd'hui qui parle
non non non elle ne fait pas de
politique elle fait ce qu'on appelle de
la méta politique c'est-à-dire qu'elle
parle de politique sans faire sans mener
le combat électoral
c'est son souhait elle a souhaité mener
une opération professionnels un projet
professionnel
en quittant l'assemblée nationale en est
heureux mais tout ce qui concourt à
irriguer l'espace mondial de nos idées
est le bienvenu et en cela elle est
utile vous parler de son projet
d'académie de sciences politiques c'est
dans le projet très politique elle dit
cette semaine elle veut développer le
terreau dans lequel tous les courants de
la droite pourront se retrouver
c'est un
petit décalage par rapport à la ligne
que porte le fruit mais marion maréchal
de concurrence idéologique entre marie
madrigal et marine le pen formidable
complémentarité marion maréchal ne se
situe pas sur le terrain électoral et
vous êtes que les victoire idéologique
précèdent toujours les victoires
politiques et donc si elle concourt à
nous aider philosophiquement
intellectuellement politiquement à
gagner les prochaines élections nous qui
sommes sur le terrain nous qui allons
devant les électeurs alors elle aura
fait un sacré bon boulot et je pense
qu'elle est utile on note que marion
maréchal-le pen est plus populaire aux
états unis que marine le pen qui avait
tenté de rencontrer dans la halle trump
pour la campagne présidentielle ça avait
été un échec
marion maréchal elle a été applaudie
c'est pas le même contexte le même
contexte marion maréchal ne vient pas en
disant qu'elle sera candidate à une
élection quelle qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
elle vient là pour développer un projet
professionnel était elle même à ses
conférences vous laissez pas c'est pas
du tout le même contexte on n'est pas
dans un rapport de force électoral et
cetera voilà donc je pense que marion
nous aide à faire à irriguer l'ensemble
de la planète de notre discours est on
en a besoin vous ne pensez pas qu elle
peut fédérer plusieurs courants de la
droite autour d'elle peut-être de la
droite mais faut aller au delà moi j'ai
toujours pensé qu'il fallait au delà
l'union de la droite c'est une chose
d'intéressant mais il faut aller là un
des nôtres faucher dlr par exemple met
d'accord mais tout ce qui va dans ce
sens là et bien et tout ce qu'elle fait
dans ce sens là va bien mais il faut
aller au delà
on a bien compris qu il fallait aussi
rassembler des gens qui ne se
reconnaissaient pas dans la droite dans
heller qui ne se reconnaissaient plus
dans la gauche etc
mais moi je suis élue d'une
circonscription ouvrière et pour
lesquels dans laquelle des gens
probablement toute leur vie voter à
gauche qui a toujours rien
parlementaires de gauche
hamon exception mais c'est parce que je
suis le représentant du front ne cesse
de dire que j'ai une conscience sociale
je ne suis pas uniquement un mec de
droite vous êtes aussi un ancien membre
du de l'ump devenu l air parlons un peu
de laurent wauquiez qui s'illustrait
avec des propos très commentée également
devant les étudiants de l'om lyon dans
un sondage qui a été fait de cette
semaine ce sont les électeurs de marine
le pen qui valide le plus ces propos est
ce qu'il ya un risque justement que son
franc parler
et bien soit appréciée dans vos rangs
mais évidemment on valide
un discours qui est celui que nous
tenons depuis très longtemps
laurent wauquiez se met à tenir le même
discours que marine le pen donc une
valise le pen c'est lui qui valident nos
idées depuis très longtemps
bah il sera certain nombre de sujets et
il a le même discours donc nous on lui
dit depuis bien longtemps parce que vous
êtes même discours venez sauf que
laurent wauquiez vous dit je veux vos
voix mais je ne veux vous pas je ne veux
je ne vous veux pas vous je ne veux pas
vos gueules
je vais bombe a coûté laurent wauquiez
il est temps plein la difficulté parce
que quelle est sa crédibilité
qu'est ce qu'il pense réellement est-ce
qu'il a un discours de façade pour
attirer des électeurs
ou est ce qu'en réalité tout ça est très
construit moi ce que je note c'est que
elle et m il est il est l'incarnation du
système
son parcours son positionnement
politique ce qu'il a défendu sur
l'europe et il essaye de jouer les anti
système donc il se prend les pieds dans
le tapis aurait été laurent wauquiez
manque cruellement de sincérité et ça
commence à se voir
il faut vous retrouvez pas un peu sur
les même électorat quand même vous alors
écoutez je partage tout d'abord notre
électorat est plus solide que celui des
républicains puisque c'est nous qui
sommes allés au second tour de la
présidentielle
donc nous avons plus d'électeurs que lui
a priori maintenant que laurent wauquiez
viennent vers nous que des républicains
viennent vers nous et nous les
accueillerons nous sommes d'accord s'il
pense sincèrement ce qu'ils disent le
problème c'est que visiblement il a
fallu de sincérité il ne pense pas ce
qu'il dit parlons pour terminer
peut-être du congrès du front national
qui va se tenir dans quelques semaines
marine le pen a choisi de placer la
question la rénovation du parti et
notamment de la question du nom du parti
au centre des débats
est-ce que c'est pas un peu une façon de
détourner justement l'attention des
militants l'attention des débats de la
question cruciale de la personne de
l'incarnation de la tête du parti par
marine le pen
non parce que je crois que parlons du
nom de nom n'est pas du tout dans le
déni on fait 35% des voix score
historique aux présidentielles 11
millions d'électeurs qui attendait cela
je crois que mélenchon et fillon aurait
rêvé d'être à notre place bon on fait ce
score il nous en manque encore pour
gagner le pouvoir
donc on se pose la question comment
faire demain comment adapter notre outil
comment adapter notre programme est ce
que notre nom pose problème pour faire
des alliances on pose tout sur la table
ont fait pas l'économie
celui là est la question la personne n'a
écouté oui puisque marine le pen est
candidate à sa réélection et que chez
nous est chez nous on vote un marvel que
chez mélenchon ses patrons ne savais pas
un dégringole du ciel etc chez nous les
adhérents votent c'est très facile en
plus d'être candidat à la présidence
donc elle elle remet en question sa
ligne elle a proposé aux militants sa
personne en tant que présidente elle a
proposé aux militants et il y aura un
vote on ne fait pas cette économie on
aurait pu dans le déni comme certains
autres certains autres après l'élection
présidentielle
non on n'en fait qu'à sa légitimé si je
puis dire mais a besoin d'être re
légitimer on a besoin d'aborder la suite
autrement on veut rassembler et on veut
gouverner
comment fait donc marine 2022 c'est
aujourd'hui la plus solide aujourd'hui
plus sûre et bien ce sera le mot de la
fin merci sébastien chenu droite est
l'invité de parlement hebdo
merci 4 ça merci sébastien chenu merci
jim on se retrouve pas la semaine
prochaine pour cause de suspension des
travaux parlementaires rendez vous donc
dans quinze jours et en attendant très
bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]